another thing that dr wright is not  allowed to do with the foundation no  using excessive force of any kind the  scp foundation isn't exactly known for  using restraint when dealing with  threats from blowing up small towns to  immersing monsters in baths of acid but  thanks to the intervention of the ethics  committee over the years the foundation  has learned to handle things a bit more  delicately when possible at least so no  one is permitted to use excessive force  unless absolutely necessary and you know  who it is never necessary for dr bright  and no dr bright excessive force is not  the same thing as the force and you know  it stop calling yourself an excessive  jedi not a thing